okay look i know that there are lego
sets and toys and things like that that
say that like that's gargantos and
doctor strange too i knew it when i made
that video but you're never going to
convince me that that's not shoe mcgrath
until i'm sitting in the movie and
doctor strange it was like it's like oh
my god guys i just got done fighting
gargantos he was that one-eyed octopus
that that i that threw a bus at me you
know like until we get that moment in
the movies you are never going to
convince me that that's not schumacher
now
in my mind schumacher makes the most
possible sense it has to be that guy
right okay those of you guys don't know
anything about schumacher you know let's
let's let's break this down like a
fraction for those of you guys who don't
know anything about shimograph i got a
great big huge long video over comics
explained that explains the whole
history of shema gorath but here's the
abridged version right so way back
before mankind existed on earth like
we're talking like billions of years the
very early days of earth you had what
were called like the great old ones or
the elder gods
they've been known as different names
right the gods of chaos or like the the
beings of sorrow or whatever they have
all kinds of different names the reason
why they have those really dark names is
because they turned earth into a hellish
landscape so you had all kinds of these
beings out there at the very top you had
two guys you had cathone and you had
shumagorath now in terms of how they got
here we don't really know we simply just
know that they were here it's largely
assumed that either they came from like
some extra dimensional space that the
things that shu mulgrath has said over
the course of his existence are actually
true that he predates reality itself and
that he basically showed up in this
universe and showed up in the main
marvel universe in marvel comics after
its creation and then occupied earth for
whatever reason we're not really given
anything as far back as where this guy
came from we simply just know that they
were there and what they would do is
they would feed on what was basically
early man right and when i say early man
i mean like eight man right primate man
right so when humans first began walking
upright and then eventually turn into
like beings you know human beings as we
know them now they were being fed on by
these guys now the reason why they left
earth are actually wide and varying
there's all kinds of reasons why that
happened when it comes to lycothon and
those guys they were basically defeated
by a tomb who went on to become the
demogorge he was originally the demiurge
basically he ate them is essentially
what it is and the ones that didn't get
eaten fled off to alternate realities
right they just literally just ran off
to alternate universes that's the nature
of catholic that's why catholic is
always trying to find a way back to
earth in the main marvel universe and he
usually uses the scarlet witch to do it
right she has like a portion of his
power which comes in the form of chaos
magic somebody like shumogorath was
actually defeated by a guy named
sizeneck now seize neg was basically
this time traveling sorcerer from the
future but he was traveling into the
past and then making these little stops
along the way to either destroy or
absorb the magical energies of various
beings that he met in order to amplify
his own power so that at the beginning
of all creation he could recreate
reality which he did he actually
succeeded in doing that for a time and
then eventually was defeated but srima
gorath was one of those guys that he
defeated but the reason why is so
significant here and really just in
terms of what he's capable of he like
most people out there like most of those
demonic beings catholic those guys he
exists in his own dimension the reason
why this is important is because much
like those guys in his home dimension
he's all powerful and he is a
multiversal force so what does that mean
okay so in marvel comics and again the
marvel cinematic universe does their own
thing so we kind of have to adapt these
concepts from marvel comics loosely
because the mcu can change it at any
point in time but in marvel comics you
you've got like planetary threats right
i mean in the grand scheme of things
these guys don't matter right you got
like ice man you got storm you got a few
people like that you know someone's the
incredible hulk whatever and then you
have like universe level threats now
there is a kind of hierarchy among
beings who are universal threats we're
just gonna lump them all together right
these are your dormammus thanos with the
infinity gauntlet mephisto uh these are
your cosmic entities the celestials
galactus franklin richards matthew
malloy just things along those lines
right just really really capable guys
somebody like gabriel shepherd is kind
of an example but these are guys that
are like really really powerful and are
a credible threat to the universe itself
and then you have multiversal threats
these are guys who are a credible threat
to the entirety of the multiverse these
are your schumagoras these are your dark
phoenixes right or like somebody with
the white phoenix of the crown this is
like the molecule man owen reese the
marquee of death king hyperion kind of
the century's evil alter ego the void
protege is another really good example
these guys are powerful right they are
credible threats now one thing to know
just because a person is a credible
threat to the multiverse doesn't mean
they could completely wipe out an entire
universe i mean most of these guys can't
right thanos with the astral regulator
thanos with the heart of the universe
these guys could wipe out all of
creation and in fact thanos ended the
multiverse when he had the heart of the
universe it was crazy but these guys are
that powerful schumachorath is on that
level that schumacher's significance in
the main marvel universe of mobile
comics is that dr strange tried to stop
him from coming into the main marvel
universe through the mind of the ancient
one and that while there was essentially
a psychic battle doctor strange couldn't
win the only way to stop super gorath
from coming through was to close the
portal the only way to do that was to
kill the ancient one so steven strange
had to kill the ancient one in order to
stop schumachorath from showing up in
the main marvel universe and that's how
steven strange officially became the
source of supreme in marvel comics but
there are multiple universes out there
that schumachorath has completely and
totally subjugated every single person
that exists in that universe is
faithful loyal to schumacher usually
because of the fact that he uses magic
or he like takes over their minds or he
just inflicts so much insane chaos and
destruction that people feel they have
no choice but to basically bend the knee
to him but this is a guy who's gone into
universes and killed those universes
versions of like galactus and different
things along those lines this guy's on a
whole different level right i mean
that's that's the thing to keep in mind
throughout the entirety of the
multiverse there's one schumacher wrath
right every universe has its own version
of dormammu right i mean it's he's cool
and i mean he's got powers but in the
grand scheme of things door mama who's a
kid with a pop gun compared to shimagura
so he's very very very very powerful now
do i think that shumogorath would serve
as something like the main villain in
doctor strange too it's possible one of
the things you guys mentioned in the
comments of the last video that we did
right the video about the doctor strange
two trailer breakdown all that kind of
stuff is that version of steven strange
could be a virgin that is wholly
possessed by schuma gorath right he's
like the living walking talking
embodiment of gorath that's entirely
possible right or he's operating as an
agent of shumagorath that's possible too
right he's been subjugated and taken one
of the things to know is that in the
comics there's been multiple times when
shumogorath has basically told doctor
strange like ally yourself with me and i
will give you power untold right stephen
strange is smart enough not to do it but
in some alternate reality somewhere yeah
some poor sat who just became the
sorcerer supreme wouldn't be too hard to
basically trick that guy especially if
he has no idea what he's doing that's
how dr strange became a disciple of
dormammu in the what if stories what if
volume 1 issue number 18 that's when
that happened right he was tricked by
dormammu because he didn't really know
any better so it's one of those things
that are that are that's really really
interesting here but chumagoras poses a
far more credible threat now do i think
that a battle between schumer gorath and
doctor strange and doctor strange ii
would come down to a battle in the
streets
with shumagorath throwing a bus at it
and doctor strange cutting it in half
probably not but it did in the mighty
avengers so here's the thing so mama
comics they have all kinds of avengers
comics right you got like the main
avengers comic then you got new avengers
and you got mighty avengers and all that
kind of stuff mighty avengers is the
version of the team at least the second
iteration was the one that luke cage led
that's the one that had spectrum monica
rambo adam brashear the blue marvel so
on and so forth right this was just a
really really cool comic there was one
point where schumachorath showed up
because dr strange had been tricked into
summoning schuma gorath by the ebony maw
it took place during the infinity
storyline when you first were introduced
to like thanos and like the cole
obsidian and those guys like the ebony
maw basically talked doctor strange
because that was that was kind of his
power he could like talk you into doing
things that you didn't want to do but he
convinced doctor strange to unleash
shumo gorath really resurrect him and
then unleash shu mugorath but that's the
thing whenever shumukura shows up on
earth you only ever see a small tiny
itty-bitty bit of its power you never
see shimogorath at full power in his own
dimension he's unstoppable and again
most of those demonic entities are
sidorak and dormammu and those guys they
really cannot be defeated in their own
realm because they've got total control
and mastery of their own realm and so
when schumachorath showed up on earth in
the mighty avengers story there's a tiny
little bit of his power right and it was
also written in such a way to where it
was basically heroes who didn't have
magical abilities defeating it right
that's why uh adam beshear just flew
through his head literally just like
just blasted right through the head of
schumacher it was still impressive right
but schumacher asked if he were to show
up at full strength
he would decimate all nobody would have
a chance like no one and when i say no
one i mean like no one right cosmic
entities magic wielders none of those
guys right he would subjugate the whole
thing i mean sure scarlet witch house of
m level power sure right she would she
would take him out right but aside from
that like he would he would decimate all
and i think having a character like that
in doctor strange too makes the most
sense because it gives you gravity right
it also gives you context if the
multiverse is really breaking down if
the multiverse is really falling apart
then it would sound more incredible that
beings like shumogorath did escape
confinement right that like he's trying
to conquer the the marvel cinematic
universe trying to conquer earth again
it begs the question why would it boil
down to a fight in the streets between
him and doctor strange but it's also one
of those things where we don't have the
full context of the scene maybe it's one
of those things where it's like the what
is it the matrix three fight scene
between like neo and like agent smith
like prime smith and like all the other
smiths are standing around watching and
it's something like that right they're
just surrounded by people who have been
subjugated by uh by by schumacher that's
possible maybe it's a more toned and
stripped down version of schumacher
right where it's not the one we know
where he has astronomical levels of
power he's just an extra dimensional
being who got in here got into the main
marvel universe her model cinematic
universe because basically reality's
breaking down and that's really it
that's really all you get right he's not
like this multiversal hell raising demi
god who's conquered entire realities
right it's not anything along those
lines that's possible too but i think
that having some sort of multiversal
extra dimensional being who shows up and
then attaching the name shimogorath to
it is huge because it shows the
significance of the threat that like it
would take someone like doctor strange
to beat that guy schumacher hath is not
an avengers level threat i don't care
what mighty avengers did right this guy
is not intimate he's way beyond that so
he's not some easily defeatable foe but
i think that having this here right
having him bishou mogorath is far more
reasonable than a one-eyed octopus from
years oh my god guys the multiverse is
falling apart and doctor strange too all
right everybody all right everybody
how do we best illustrate the collapse
of the multiverse in the opening
sequence of the film i know kevin feige
let's have a one-eyed octopus from the
atlantic ocean that comes from atlantis
let's have it attack the surface world
and doctor strange defeats it
genius
[Laughter]
i'm sorry i just i can't get behind that
right i cannot i cannot in good
conscience get behind that it's got to
be schumacher maybe it's not but i feel
like it is with that being said guys
we're gonna bring this to an end thank
you guys for watching and i will catch
you all later
peace